[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Scott Hastings played in
the NBA member of the 1990 Bad Boy
Pistons now a color analyst with the
Nuggets he will join us here in a moment
but I want to play what Eric Spoelstra
had to say Ramona Shelburne of the
mothership asked the question which I
thought was a fair question Eric
Spoelstra did not think so this is
probably oversimplifying things but
sometimes when when teams play against
yokits you turn them into a score you
turn him into a pass or any controls the
game he only had four assists tonight
yeah that's ridiculous you know it's
just that's the untrained eye that says
something like that this guy's an
incredible player twice in two seasons
he's been the best player on this planet
you can't just say
oh make him a score
that's not how they play they they have
so many different actions that just get
you compromised we have to focus on what
we do
um you know we try to do things the hard
way and he requires you to do many
things the hard way and then we he has
our full respect okay thank you thank
you coach okay and it's a walk-off too
I don't know why that bothered him so
much unless he's really careful of
trying to oversimplify the Joker so the
compliment would be
um hey he can score he can pass if we
can limit one and maybe you know uh is
really good at the other one we still
feel like we can win
he's gone over 43 times in the playoffs
they've lost all three times are you
trying to make him one dimensional how
do you make him one-dimensional I I
don't I don't think that's a
Preposterous question
it felt like and she's even saying I'm
oversimplifying here
but it uh
that was it like a Greg Popovich you
know untrained eye
you never played the game
yeah Paul if you're Ramona Shelburne
after game three you raise your hand say
coach like you I never played an NBA
game what are your thoughts on Jimmy
Butler's blank blank no if Joker goes
off and has like 12 assists and has you
know 25 points uh coach I might be
oversimplifying this but it looked like
you were uh uh trying to let him be a
passer tonight not a scorer your
thoughts coach yes and he's like he
throws the untrained eye thing at Ramona
Shelburne which was really unfair and
just rude but then like there's
literally former players who are working
as analysts now saying the exact same
thing I'm pretty would that consider
would they be considered a trained eye
um you would think but bam out of Bio
was talking about that prior to the
start of the series that if you can make
him one-dimensional
Scott Hastings joins us now no the
Nuggets uh TV color analyst former NBA
player and was at last night's game let
me start there with spoolstra and uh
what he had to say in response to Ramona
shelburne's question is that is that
logical to approach the Denver Nuggets
that hey if we limit uh Joker to uh just
scoring that we can beat him
well
here's here's the take on words that
that statement makes in my opinion
um it's not joking people involved you
know I keep a stat uh because this came
up a couple years ago well you know just
let Joker get his and so I I do the
games I'm calling them on radio still
and I'll keep a stat how many you know
kick out missed shots Drive the best and
gotta lay up get fouled right where you
you get free throws but you don't get an
assist he had eight of those last night
so if all those shots are hit all sudden
he has 12 assists to go with his other
stats
that's a pretty good night so I I don't
think it's always let him get his listen
we all we all need a little help once in
a while you know and I and I I thought
like I said
Michael Porter you know had another bad
shooting night
um one of seven I think from the
three-point line and you know when
you're a guy inside and and you watch
their game you see him I mean there's
bodies around him wherever he's going
and anybody want to tell me they let
Joker get 41 last night I'm not sure
they watch that game because I mean they
were all over him
I thought after game one Miami had open
looks they just didn't make them so I
thought that that was a deceiving win by
Denver that Miami didn't play that well
now you have Miami not winning and Jimmy
Butler not playing that well and now you
go to game three in Miami so what is the
expectation level
uh I think
I think a little bit of game two I think
um both teams want to shoot the ball
letter uh better I thought Duncan
Robinson who had had zero points at half
they let him get started and and you
know you let a guy get hot all of a
sudden that's that's the thing in My
Hope for you know Porter Jr and even in
the broadcast last night when he made
that one little layup I'm like well
maybe now I've seen the ball go in
um listen I I said this before I I think
Denver's probably a better team on paper
um going people that really play on
paper anymore or puppy dogs so I don't
think that means much
um but I think it's gonna be a good
series I and this hey what's the old
saying the series doesn't start until
somebody wins on the road and guess what
Miami just yeah made the first statement
the series has started
what's the adjustment now that Denver
makes to counteract the adjustments that
Miami made
well first of all we're heading out
today so we're I'm getting on my Ricky
Martin uh DVDs out and and music okay I
figured and a Miami sound machine so I
figured that would kind of get me in the
mood okay uh I'm thinking about sending
some of those soundtracks to Malone to
see kind of play for the guys to get him
ready
um the physicality listen
um
you can't win and I and I really do and
I say this respect think this is a
softer league right now I just kind of
weigh the nature of basketball's turn
more finesse if you will great athletes
better athletes than there's ever been
in the history of the world top to
bottom you got guys that we're never
going to know their names in in five or
ten years that are 10 times the athletes
of dudes in a you know that we're still
thinking about
um
but I still think in this time in this
series and and this time of
stuff on the line that that the more
physical teams going to win this series
and Miami
you know like I said a couple calls the
game changes but I think Miami is a more
physical team last night he's Scott
Hastings the Nuggets color analyst
former NBA player member of the 1990
Champion Pistons did you guys have to
talk about what the philosophy was on
the Pistons to beat up Michael Jordan
uh
no it was almost
something and it was
Jordan rules and I remember them talking
about
yeah so we know how to play without a
plan and I remember uh Brenda Malone
Michael Malone's dad he and I would
drive to the airport and said well no
what is you know the Jordan rules what
are those well here's what it is and
um no then it became listen that was
like a tattoo you came in and that was
that was you know you knew exactly what
that that was but Chuck Daly never spoke
about beating up Jordan
every time I've beaten him up we just
said no labs I mean I mean it was it was
done nicely we were gentlemen Dan yeah
so to speak
um no it was it was we wanted to get up
on him when he got the ball
when he got rid of the ball you aren't
letting him catch it and he was getting
no lips that that was the three simple
rules basically that we had but I wonder
if you guys changed the NBA by the way
you played against him therefore he
started lifting weights you made Jordan
even better
because of the physicality that the bad
boy Pistons had well the the little
documentary that came out member of
Jordan in the middle of coal but he kind
of he kind of admitted that and
yeah you know if we were just nicer to
him then maybe
and you know also maybe you know we
could have won a couple more in Detroit
but
um listen this
first of all I still think he's one of
the most special people that's ever
played this game and I don't care if
anybody get in the argument of who's
this and who's that but
um there's just in nature you and I
could go back to the the mid 80s Lakers
Celtics when the the well the clear path
is what it's called now rule
first came in the table because remember
their their clothesline lamb is on the a
Rambis on the fast break and doing all
this stuff so the game has changed a and
they say for health health and safety or
whatever I I say it's because they just
don't want you know to see somebody
decapitated right there on live TV and I
can understand that
um but you gotta adjust how to play and
that that's another thing also that I
don't think is talked about enough
um and I don't like things that I don't
like officials but that's that's not
here or there you and I write a book
about that
um but each one has their distinct
personality you've got to understand
what that personality is
and you've got to play to that
personality uh Daryl Garrettsville the
great uh late great Daryl Garrison you
knew that was going to be a a
tough physical game because he didn't
want to call a lot of fouls he had to
adjust uh Earl Straub you saw him
walking the building you were hoping you
were the visiting team
Jake O'Donnell he rewarded hustle I mean
these are three legendary NBA coaches in
its same way and I you got to know the
personality guys and you got to point to
them uh I think the league wants this
more of a finesse athletic game and
that's what's turned into but
sure seems like to me in the finals The
More Physical team wins safe travels
Scott always great to talk to you buddy
you know what Dan I just want to say I
miss you I love you and I need you in my
life
well keep winning and then because if
you know I'd like I'm a front runner if
you guys don't win and Scott no I'll be
I'll be uh calling you to talk about the
Broncos
yeah yeah well I know you won't ever
talk about that that's crazy about that
I guarantee of 50 70 a thousand times
trying to get Bronco guests I think
we'll work hey all I know is Russ is
leaner and meaner that's all I need this
year for uh Russ Let's Ride
I don't know what that means but he's
leaner and meaner yeah I I I'm leaner
here in the last couple weeks too and I
still can't get up off this couch
thank you Scott
see you buddy
Scott Hastings former